right now there are 162 satellites in
orbit
measuring the earth's climate the data
they measure is
important it informs agriculture weather
prediction
and perhaps most importantly the surface
temperatures they measure
inform government action or inaction on
climate change but what if i told you
that those satellites can be
wrong in measuring the earth's
temperature by several degrees
celsius and that those incorrect
satellite measurements go into climate
models that can be off
by 20 degrees the explanation of why
involves a giraffe some universities
and this gravel monkey thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video
to support your learning in science and
maths outside of the classroom
go to the link in the description this
is dr tom
dowling long-term viewers of the channel
may recognize him from the crash course
cryosphere that we made together here
these days he's a scientist at the
national center for earth observation
using a technique called remote sensing
essentially all the remote sensing is
it's actually what we're doing here like
with this camera
remote sensing is being physically
removed from something
and measuring it to say take temperature
as a key example here
if you touch something you can feel how
hot it is you are directly sensing
how hot it is whereas if you had a
thermal camera
that's you know mounted on anything it
could be a drone could be a satellite
could be an aircraft
and that camera tells you this point is
this hot
you have remotely sensed that
temperature rather than contact sense
the temperature
there are lots of ways that a satellite
can measure the earth's temperature but
to be specific
tom is looking at a very widely used
satellite called
seviri uses what's called the radiative
method
basically measuring the infrared
radiation given off by the earth's
surface a bit like a thermal camera
essentially you look at how much
radiation is in one
portion of the spectrum how much
radiation in another and then do some
maths between that and that can tell you
how
hot the surface of the earth is that
maths obviously uses
thermal physics to convert a measurement
by a satellite into a temperature
on the ground but the equations involved
need certain numbers to be put into them
certain
parameters which can only be measured on
the ground
and dr dowling was interested in a
particularly important parameter called
the emissivity of the ground so the
emissivity is
essentially simply how good an object is
at retaining or readmitting uh radiation
in the thermal portion of the spectrum
in this case so for example if you've
got a perfect emitter
all the energy and radiation comes into
it or is present in it
is emitted so it's perfectly it's one
essentially but also that's never true
and it's particularly not true at a
multi-kilometer scale which is what
we're working at here
where you've got plants growing all over
the place you've got trees you've got
bare soil you've got water
all have different emissivity properties
what does that mean for your temperature
you need this number to calculate the
temperature how do you know what this
number is and how do you get it
this may not seem like much of a problem
like should you just go out into the
wild and measure how emissive
reflective everything is and then you're
done
you've got the parameter and people have
done this and they've mostly done a good
job but the problem is that
well satellites break the earth's
surface down into
pixels with each pixel being up to a few
kilometers across
for the benefit of americans watching
that means they can be over
500 bald eagles wide within a pixel
different processes affect the overall
emissivity
for example tree cover changing over the
year changes how reflective the land is
in different months
as do changes in surface moisture and
what kind of rock is underfoot
scientists went out and established what
are called validation stations
here they measure the relevant
parameters like emissivity
and send those numbers to the remote
observation people to use
in their equations they then compare
what the satellite thinks the
temperature should be in their pixel
using the parameters they measured like
emissivity with the temperature they
measure
on the ground this process is called
validation and it's absolutely essential
for science
the problem is the scientists set up
these validation stations
close to where their universities were
if you look at a map
of land surface temperature what i'm
interested in here validation stations
there are two in the continent of africa
and then there's like
50 in america yeah that's the kind of
disparity you're looking at
and that is significant because the
processes that take place within a given
pixel
will depend on where that pixel is so
while scientists might have measured how
a forest in north america
affects the emissivity of the pixel it's
in a forest in sub-saharan africa
might have completely different effects
on the emissivity of its pixel
and different again from the effects
that a forest in southeast asia might
have on the emissivity of
its pixel quite apart from having
different species different trees within
the forests they may grow in a
completely different way
over the course of a year one of the
very big differences between
where we've established this how in
kenya and your typical kind of tempera
zone or even north american as a whole
zone
uh is that you've got bimodal rainfall
patterns so it's a semi-arid savannah
your vegetation is dead cenest being the
technical term
i'm not a biologist it's dead but it's
all there still it's just
brown stuff and a lot of algorithms that
get your emissivity number from a
satellite
they use green and near infrared light
to tell you how much plant stuff is
there
and if it's got all the plants there it
says use this number if it says there's
not much plants there
use that number what happens when you've
got
dead plant there this means then that
the temperature a satellite returns for
a given pixel
can be obtained using numbers using
parameters
in the equations that are just woefully
inappropriate they're just
wrong and to be more specific those
numbers are more likely to be wrong
if the pixel contains vegetation of some
kind and is away
from europe and north america where
basically all the vegetation emissivity
data has come from
and to be as clear as i can that covers
a lot of the world
actually this is one of the big things
that came out of the paris agreement
is that quite rightly places around the
tropics uh
and um in the global south said well
hang on you want us to make all these
changes
we don't we don't know your data is any
good for our locality how do we know
what's happening with climate change in
our part of the world
and that's one of my personal drivers is
to you know help fix that and change
that
technology transfer and also going out
and doing the measurements with people
from the area
as he hinted at earlier tom went out to
kenya as part of this work to set up a
validation station
for savannah in a place called kapiti
we are working with the in-country
partner
ilri the international livestock
research institute
and we were establishing this on their
research ranch
which is about two hours southeastern
nairobi called kapiti
and kapiti is fantastic because it's a
managed rangeland savannah
and they do science there so the first
challenge was basically getting my head
around
all these moving parts where's the
equipment gotta go
i i ended up shipping two and a half
tons of equipment to kenya
just about fitted it all in two land
rovers uh and then drove it out to the
site then we had to build it
so it's amazing how much an a level in
design and technology
comes in useful there's i remember very
strongly i was an a-level
sixth former people visiting like whose
kids were going to come in
i said hey i love design tech i like
being a bit practical i like putting
stuff together
and some somewhat snobby older gentleman
said oh you're going to
grammar school what are you doing in the
woodwork shop
well let me tell you sir it turns out
practical skills very handy in science
before we dig
into the results of tom's research
though and just how wrong the satellites
and models can be
i just want you to hear this story of
how
field work can be a bit different to
theory and how stuff can
go wrong in ways that you would never
plan for
competi is an amazing place um so they
have
a lot of cattle there but they also have
a lot of zebra
uh they have lion there's hyena there's
eagle
there's all kinds of stuff and in
particular there are giraffes
now i don't know if you've ever been to
a savannah but generally fairly flat
which is one reason why you're attracted
to it because we didn't have to deal too
many slope issues with our validation
effort
whilst still getting the vegetation
element nailed down
uh with a few trees sticking up now
obviously giraffes
quite tall you know we're installing
masts which are
15 to 20 meters tall and
giraffes are very curious intelligent
animals particularly when you put a 15
to 20 meter tall
shiny thing up in the air and it's got a
little bit of fence around it but not
too much because you want the natural
grazing to
on the surface around where you're
monitoring um
and unfortunately about two months after
we'd installed it i think a giraffe
i like to say it got a bit amorous it
was a slightly amorous giraffe
got a bit close up and personal uh and
to be honest it probably it got
uh got its leg caught on one of the guy
lines possibly
probably and panicked now giraffes are
strong it turns out because these are
aluminium
and steel masts that are you know
20 centimeters diameter at the base bent
in half
completely ripped out the ground bent in
half all my very expensive delicate
instruments smashed into the ground
and in fact we had a wildlife monitoring
camera that caught the culprit
uh walking away from the scene somewhat
of a crazy angle
because obviously it was now all on the
ground so yeah i lost
i lost one of my masts to a to a randy
giraffe
it's stuff like this that made me do a
theoretical phd not a practical one
post reconstruction what did tom find
satellites there's a satellite called
modis which a lot of the world relies on
it's a us satellite and it's generally
speaking
more wrong than the initial validation
work that was done in the past has shown
in particular and this is a running
theme actually through a lot of the
sensors
they they struggle when the surface
temperature is really high
and also this is something that the
models are struggling with we can not
only validate
satellites which are measuring these
surfaces we can also validate the global
climate circulation models
and local weather prediction models who
have surface temperature as an element
within them
and see how correct they are we measured
a variety of different models and
sensors and the overall message is
they're okay
they're not as good as people think they
are probably because the
more this more complex environment is
basically less well represented or less
well coped with
the key message really is that we're
there's a cold bias
in nearly all of these things all
particularly models are really bad at it
but also a lot of the satellite sensors
are not capturing the true peak surface
temperatures
now this is really important because
you're missing a lot of energy from the
system
and also if you look at agriculture
applications
crops can really suffer when the
temperatures get really high
and also the insects that feed on them
behave differently under different
temperatures
so if you've got your temperature wrong
by
up to potentially 20 kelvin for some of
these things
that's a lot of energy missing that's a
lot of heat and surface temperature
missed
and so that's that's a real concern if
you came into this video expecting me to
say that
satellites and climate models are
predicting too much warming and the
world is staying at the same temperature
always has after all
i'm afraid the data indicates the exact
opposite
because of biases in how satellite
observations work specifically in
applying parameters like the emissivity
that have been measured almost
entirely in europe and america our
satellite measurements are specifically
underestimating how hot things are
getting during the day
in places like africa and climate models
are
even worse at this and outside of places
in the developed world have
a more substantial cold bias something
that i want to stress however
is that scientists are aware of these
problems this is
why tom is doing this work science is a
process that needs validation data
like this and continually iterates and
improves and
gets closer and closer to representing
the real world in equations and
data at the moment however there
is reason to believe that the tropics
and the global south without
appropriate parameterization of things
like vegetation are actually
substantially hotter in the day
than we currently think they are and
we'll be
harder hit by climate change than the
models currently suggest
i wanted to bring you the story a
because it shows some of the complexity
in
global modern science and b because it
also shines light on
the essential but not exactly glamorous
work of validation
but mostly because it shows how bad
science
still is at utilizing expertise that
comes from somewhere
other than the developed world something
i'm still struggling to get right
um it's there's very little funding in
it
when you put in a funding proposal um
it can be hard to get the money to
enable it because it takes money and
time
to build the relationships to enable um
academics in the host country to get
involved
you need funding to enable that and it
has to be budgeted properly which it so
rarely is
and it's a huge loss not only is it you
know
morally dubious to say the least to go
into a country get the data
leave and give nothing back it's also
you're losing out on so much
i learned so much about the biology and
the vegetation cycling that's
vital to know about in terms of
answering the questions um
from working with the people who funnily
enough live and work there people do
still forget about it and it's something
that i think
one of the solutions is for funding
agencies to make it a compulsory part of
overseas field work which it certainly
isn't at the moment but also to
recognize the effort and work that goes
into making it happen
properly in dealing with climate change
the stakes
could not be higher and as tom's work
shows
we're not doing a good enough job
measuring anywhere other than the west
validating anywhere other than the west
working with anyone other than
in the west asian countries like china
and india are building up their
facilities and their expertise and
working closely with scientists in the
west but
we in the west need to do more we need
to support
science in the developing world in the
global south
and i am proud to call tom my friend for
doing his bit
in trying to combat this really
important
problem let's say for the warhammer game
we played after this interview though
whereas eldar beat my space marines tom
you boss science in school is really
just memorizing equations
it's passive but in reality as this
video shows
the subject is active science is a doing
word you science by doing by solving
problems with theory and data
this means that the way we learn science
in school isn't really the best way to
do so the best way to learn it is by
solving problems and developing
understanding by getting stuff
wrong and improving this is exactly how
educational website brilliant.org and
its associated app
work brilliant is a perfect companion to
learning scientific material
that could be physics chemistry computer
science biology
maths in school by presenting you with
problems that start easy and get harder
i've said it before and i'll say it
again if i was in school or university
now
i would be using brilliance to
strengthen my learning
with daily challenges to introduce you
to new subjects countless quizzes
perfect for revision and inspirational
content beyond the curriculum like
quantum computing and machine learning
brilliant is the perfect companion to
any science student to get access to all
this
or to gift access to a student in your
life go to brilliant.org
simon clark and the first 200 people who
go to that link will even get 20
off their annual subscription if you
like this video
you'll love brilliant so go check them
out thank you
so much for watching and thanks of
course must go to
dr tom dowling for being so generous
with his time
less so for being so generous with his
eldar's firepower as i said earlier i
think the work that tom is doing is
really important
and if you would like to learn more
there are links down there in the
description to tom's work
and also to the organizations he worked
with out in kenya
if you enjoyed the video you know what
to do you can like it you can comment
you can share it with friends if you
want to see more you can subscribe
you're not new to youtube i don't need
to tell you this
basically just thank you for watching i
hope you enjoyed it and learned
something and
i'll see you the next one